les faits remontent à vendredi en fin
d'après midi la directrice de cette
agence immobilière d'auxerre seront à
venoix hante une commune toute proche
elle a rendez vous pour visiter un
logement avec celui qu'elle croit être
un client
mais l'homme va l'a menacé avec une arme
et l'obligé à l'emmener jusqu'à blois la
femme restée injoignable ses proches
s'inquiètent
dans la soirée ils lancent sur les
réseaux sociaux une alerte et un appel
pour la retrouver
le lendemain samedi elle sera libérée en
début de matinée sur le parking de la
gare de bois par son ravisseur qui prend
la fuite à bord du véhicule de la
victime celle ci parvient à joindre son
mari avec son téléphone portable qui
vient la chercher et la ramène à auxerre
que s'est il passé dans l'intervalle
pour l'instant le flou demeure sur
l'identité et les motivations de
l'agresseur
une enquête pour enlèvement et
séquestration a été ouverte pour
identifier et arrêter l'auteur des faits
soulagé mais encore sous le choc la
famille de la jeune femme n'a pas
souhaité s'exprimer